usa today reports that volkswagen is
bringing back that
famous vw van uh it goes into production
next year and it's a little different
than it used to be because this minibus
is going to be fully
electric yeah it looks great too
it's called the id buzz and it will get
270 miles per charge and have
some self-driving features as well look
at the dashboard in there that is not
your
grandmother's vw bug i remember you
talking about
traveling in a big volkswagen uh bus
i used to have a volkswagen van again
yeah you did oh yeah so are you going to
get this one
i have been excited for this because
this has definitely been being
advertised for
a really long time yeah they announced
it first like in 2017 and then it's just
been in the works
yep yep yep so maybe their timing is now
um i keep staring at that steering wheel
going like how am i going to put my hand
through it to like
pull it it's literally shaped like a
it's
a rectangle um but i am excited i'm glad
it's electric this is so exciting
and um you know who doesn't love all the
volkswagen bugs and vanigans and you
know the whole nines
and you can't steer with your knee with
that thing either right and you know
your knee would be up like this yeah
you can't do it totally i think road
trips are going to be massive
now uh when when the world sort of gets
back to normal people are so hungry
to get out there and travel i'm going to
travel in one of those well also i drive
a minivan so that my kids can be like
way back in their own world and it looks
like that's the setup
do you really drive a minivan oh yeah
okay i am not saying this with any
judgment my fantasy car is a minivan
because all the rich parents had one
right you know what i'm talking about
where like
they could fit everyone in there i
always wanted the two side doors that
open so whenever i get a rental car when
i travel i totally get a minivan
girl get into my car can i ride in your
minivan sometime
oh my god just take me around the block
i caught i
literally it's like you'll have to share
it with like
mcdonald's rappers dogs and kids yeah
that's how i want it that's
yes i wanna play oh fish wrapper on the
floor in the corner yeah
it's there rossi oh my god this is so
fun okay let's go
okay great we'll do it maybe we can film
it and show it to all of you guys how
about that
it's happening okay great
you